I took a brown one is that like dog poo
or something oh no that was rotten egg
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no oh no it's liver and onions
[Music]
hi I'm Florence Pugh and this is snack
Wars Us versus UK the loud Bible
cheddar cheese with some brownston
pickle
Mel sibuku
and what is that this is a pickle oh I
think I'm gonna like this but let me try
my favorite first okay what do you like
about it Browns and pickle yeah it's
classic dad's favorite sandwich always
in the fridge even with your old cheese
it works
the right amount
I mean
probably a bit too much Brownstone with
the ratio of cheese
but it's still going to be tasting great
delish now we're gonna try this
that doesn't look healthy oh man
sniff to Hurst
I'm confused about the shape though but
hey all cucumbers come in all shapes and
sizes
oh
this looks weird
look how much juice is dripping out of
it yeah they must have soaked that for a
long time oh it's pickled sure that
would make sense thing is though is I
sometimes have that on cheese so let's
try yes
I think I'm gonna have to go down to
packaging Branston
oh
I got off so hard my mic came off okay
right I think I know what I'm gonna like
m s call on the caterpillar AKA
everyone's birthday present forever I
mean birthday cake story yeah look how
cute he is though
yeah he's so cute and then we have the
classic original glazed Krispy Kreme
which is what my birthday cakes are made
up of really yeah and birthday presents
actually I've been given I think she's
gonna rip the Box big funny because you
know I can I actually played a game the
other day where it was like if you had
24 18 12 and 3 and I give you five
things that you do which order would you
put them at and my 24 was I would
happily eat 24 Krispy Kremes wow that's
a great game I know so I think you may
already know what I like but I'm gonna
do it challenges eat all of it I'll do
that
I just made eye contact with you and I
ate that donut there was that a bit
weird
it's nice and gooey in it they just
dissolve in the mouth you want one you
know what I will so much thank you so
much
icing went in between the thighs where
are you going top or bottom I'm gonna
chop his bum okay
little swirl little tushy
really but then that's just solid
chocolate yeah
foreign
it is nice I'm gonna go with the us
though on this one yeah I can just hear
faint children screaming yeah how could
you
oh say we have jelly beans and we have
love hearts yeah yeah love hearts
sentimental we always used to fish
through the packets and give it to the
one that we fancied being like I fancy
you and then they'd always put it in
their mouth without looking at it and
like
you're mine
[Music]
simple they know what they're doing
they've got emojis on them now don't
know how I feel about that yeah okay
let's try them
okay
you have to spin it yeah okay and then
whatever it is I have to eat it even if
it's vomit is this the yucky one
okay lovely I can give out the way love
hearts yeah yeah
pomegranate or old bandage oh
old bandage okay I presume that's the
red one right yeah
[Music]
I mean that's probably pomegranate
bogey or juicy Pearl um
[Music]
um salty must be bogey yeah I got a
bogey that's tasting Burger though go
with the young you know nostalgic love
hearts or the or the game I think that's
because I'll go to I'll do the beans
yeah okay
I took a brown one is that like dog pill
or something
oh no that was rotten egg oh no no no no
no no no no no no no no oh no it's liver
and onions oh
I'm gonna change my bedroom
how do you love hearts okay
oh I do need a beer now
okay we have
beef jerky
oh that smells a bit pongy I love it
yep I actually hate this so much I do
[Applause]
scratchings I don't like the crazy fatty
bits I like
fine why are everyone like that that's a
pretty plain one you want a bit yeah
we have one yeah okay well my book
scratchings thanks sorry you asked me to
deliver oh I'm happy now
and then you're like literally one of
the first people to like both of these
really yeah I really I like the really
spicy ones as well
and they hurt but these are great
okay
so we've got fish and chips obvi and
we've got is that a deep dish it is a
mini deep dish weird apologies in
advance that's okay is it a bit strange
what's in here is that mushy peas yeah
oh yes okay in your fan yeah
great stuff
I was actually a bit hungry this is
perfect
yeah I like that yes yeah now we have a
little petite deep dish yes a little
tiny a tiny little petite deep dish yeah
very good using the knife I know and
most people are gonna hate me for that
aren't they
we want to make sure I get all the tiny
pepperoni pieces in
oh
okay if I was hungover I'd do that but I
think every day I'd do that fish and
chips UK what
oh I'm just gonna go straight to this
one yeah not even gonna touch that
it also goes with your outfit perfectly
what do you like about it
Nostalgia yeah
lunch boxes I had like loose bits of
fruit at the bottom of my bag
no added sugar no added sugar yeah we're
helping children
not hindering them
okay of course sorry not fine I'm okay
hey that's you
oh
my goodness
there you go
England
game the UK
man what was your favorite I think it
probably had to be I like the beer and
the pork scratchings yeah okay great you
may take that with me no thank you so
much it's in all different forms of
pastries okay wait a minute wait a
minute really no hold on
laughs
you uh you weren't there for me thank
you